hey everyone and welcome back to episode
number 17 of the beginner to master
Speed Run coming into today rated
1057 and I think the goal will be to get
to 1100 so we'll see how many games that
will take but let's just hop into
it and playing Jeffrey Norbert okay I'll
play Pawn
E4 and we have a French defense I think
this might be the first first French of
the
speedrun and against this opening uh
usually recommend just taking the center
and there's a few different moves here
um E5 is Advanced variation Pawn takes
Pawn is exchange variation there is
Knight C3 and Knight D2 to defend the
pawn uh there's a lot of different other
things that I can play against the
French uh I'm going to play the move
Knight D2 and in the previous episode I
was was playing some openings I played
when I was much younger and this is
another opening that um I learned around
the age of like 9 or 10 years old my
first chess coach taught me so figure
I'll stick with this this is called the
Tash
variation and there are a lot of
different moves black can play from here
uh Knight E7 definitely not the most
common move because it blocks in the
bishop um more common is take or Knight
to
F6 but from here I I do have a choice um
I could
advance but I think I'm better off just
developing uh play Knight to
F3 and if black wants to take I can
still recapture with a
knight
so yeah this move I don't think
harmonizes well with uh Black's position
because it's a question how the bishop
will develop and then eventually how
black will
Castle very often in the French black
likes to play the move C5 but now that
the Knight is blocking the bishop C5
might just be a free Pawn temporary Free
Pawn so opponent taking some time here
plays Pawn
A6 kind of a slow move um it's not a
move that I can easily punish I think
against a move like this it's still just
a matter of following principles
developing controlling the center Bishop
D3 reinforces E4 prepares to Castle now
of course the downside of having my
knight on D2 it does block this bishop
so uh I guess we see kind of a similar
case with both of our Knights blocking
the darks for Bishop uh the benefit of
playing this move though is it does
allow for C3 there's lines where the
Knight goes to C3 and then white can't
play this move to reinforce the
center and speaking of C3 I think I'm
going to play
this right
now uh cuz black was applying a bit more
pressure against the pawn also uh C Pawn
restricts Knight B4 which maybe was an
idea so very solid position for white so
far
and yeah we'll see how black attempts to
develop the Bishops we see Knight G6
this is a very logical move now black
does have some idea of Knight F4
attacking the undefended bishop on D3 as
well as the pawn on
G2 and I have a choice here I could play
Knight to
F1
to unleash my Bishop prevent Knight F4
then maybe prepare Knight to
G3 um I can also Castle two
to guard G2 and then if Knight F4 I drop
back the
bishop couple options
here I kind of like the idea of Knight
F1 it's a little bit strange to play
this move like so early in the game
before
castling but just the prospect of
opening the bishop and preparing Knight
G3 ises nice and the bishop is covering
E4 so if takes I don't mind taking back
with the
bishop so playing very very solidly so
far in the previous speedrun episode I
was playing a lot of aggressive games
there a lot of games where I was
sacrificing material to get some early
initiative early
attacks uh but this is a different style
just trying to find the best SES for the
pieces um maybe playing a little bit
more slowly keeping the tension in the
center Knight H4
interesting not a move that I was
anticipating black is attacking the pawn
on G2 if I take the queen could take I
should note here like Bishop G5 maybe
looks good at first but that would be a
blunder because Knight takes F3 comes
with check and then Queen takes G5 would
be
possible
so yeah I'm inclined to just take the
Knight and then develop and reinforce
the
pawn I don't think I mind Black's Queen
coming
out like this it's hard to exploit the
queen I could play
G3 but then that takes away the square
for my knight I think I'll just leave
the queen
on
H4 prepare to Castle really try and
focus on the
center and if Bishop D6 then I'll be
happy to play Pawn E5 and this may be
possible like going forward into the
middle game if black doesn't take on e4
the plan might be to play E5 castle and
then go for the expansion with F4 F5
really try and gain space in the center
and on the king
side Queen d8 wow
okay so black spending a couple Tempe
with the
queen nine moves into the game I have
two minor pieces developed black has one
minor piece we did trade a a pair of
knights
so yeah I'm just going to Castle I'm
leaving the pawn tension still and these
pawns have been staring at each other
for the last so many moves like most of
the
game um but again I don't mind if if
takes it helps me act activate in this
case probably the
bishop and I still want to keep the
option open like if Bishop D6 I would
play
E5 I think now it's time to just play
E5 closing down the
center I am winning Connect
4 but this is very typical in the French
to get this sort of structure and
usually black likes to play a move like
C5 to at least exert some pressure
against my uh my Pawn
chain but can't easily be done in this
position and black is cing into a
potential attack like I already have the
bishop and Knight aimed the king
side a move like Queen H5 comes to mind
simply threatening
Checkmate yeah I'm going to play King
I'm going to play Queen
H5 threatening to checkm the black
king and there's a com principle in
chess I forgot where I I saw this maybe
in some kind of Chess book but when you
have a Pawn on E5 and your white and
your opponent has Castle
kingside uh the general principle is you
should try and attack on the king side
because you have more space the pieces
have more room to uh maneuver and
control
squares uh the other principle is you
should attack on the side that your Pawn
chain is pointing
towards and yeah this case Pawn chain is
pointing towards the king
side so with Queen H6 I'm dreaming of
someday checkmating on
G7 and my dream might come
true in this position I I think there's
a very very powerful
move
which I feel like this position is kind
of like a puzzle if anyone's watching
that wants to pause the video and find
the move for white feel free to do so
the move I'm going to play is Knight
H5 and this exploits the fact that the
pawn on G6 is pinned to H7 so black
takes I can Checkmate and meanwhile I'm
threatening the main on
G7 there's really not much black can do
to survive pretty sure it was force mate
there the engine actually saying maen
three so kind of an Abrupt finish like
very solid opening I really wasn't
trying to like win quickly this game I
was trying to just follow principles
achieve uh some nice peace Harmony yeah
this move KN F1 um this is reminiscent
of what you sometimes see in the Spanish
or Italian what we call the the Spanish
night walk the night goes from D2 to F1
and then eventually redevelops to the
king
side and I think the main mistake from
black in this game was playing a little
bit slowly like moving the knights a
bunch of times to trade it off
and then yeah just putting the queen
back and then castling into danger uh
usually in the opening you should Castle
but in this case maybe it was better for
black to hold off on committing the king
to the king side and just going back
further I mean maybe Black's problems
stem with this move Knight
E7 uh like the main moves are Pawn takes
Pawn Knight F6 or even C5 to pressure
the center right
away so um nice first game let's keep it
going new tenament game playing JP
lell and we have Pawn B3 This Is A nimzo
Larson attack uh the move I like to play
here is Pawn E5 just put the pawn in
Center follow opening
principles develop and defend the
pawn um D3 not the most common move
usually most players play E3 to develop
the bishop but D3 I think I'll just play
Pawn D5
control the
center and white is playing the
beginning of what we can call a hippo
setup the hippo is a pretty generic
setup where white puts the pieces like
this and tries to be very
solid so I'm also going to be or I'm
also going to try and be solid but I'm
going to try and be a bit more active
and control more space uh we'll start
with Bishop to D6 simply rein forcing
the
pawn and there's a plan that I usually
like to go for against the
hippo um sometimes it's hard to achieve
I was going to say that if white were to
play G3 then I would go for the early
Rook Pawn thrust of H5
H4 but with Pawn
H3 not sure if H5 really accomplishes
much I could go for this move actually
Pawn A5 the idea is to play Pawn A4 and
eventually try and harass a bishop on
the queen side of course another plan is
just to be solid and castle and carry on
with life yeah I think I'll just Castle
first bit more standard type
play and okay white expanding with G4 so
yeah this is not the typical hippo move
like usually hippo players like to play
G3 so with this
move I mean there is a prospect of
G5 but one of the first things that come
to mind is the prospect for black to
eventually play
F5 and open the f file and maybe provoke
some weaknesses against White's King
side uh of course I can play F5 with the
Knight here
so a move like Knight E8 or Knight
D7 like even though it looks p
passive I think it's a move that I'd
like to go
for if I play Knight D7 it blocks in the
bishop so what I'm going to do here is
develop the bishop
first and I mean I have pretty qu
quintessential development with the
knights and Bishops supporting my Center
pawns uh but from here I'm going to go
for Knight to
D7 getting out of the way of
thaton and I really just want to open a
a file open the f file for The
Rook um of course early on in the game
you always have to be careful moving the
F Pawn whether or not you're castled
because sometimes it does weaken the
king but in this case I'm not really
creating any
weaknesses King is very hard for white
to
attack even though maybe someday white
can try and coordinate the bishop and
The Rook using the G file I think
there's way more upside with black
attacking on the
file
so yeah I think this is the first kind
of big decision for white like what to
do with this tension White's leaving the
tension this move does exert more
pressure against F5 it also unleashes a
queen so I can't actually win a pawn by
taking and now I have a decision to make
and I could leave the tension I could
take
I could also play
F4 which honestly looks the most
attractive just move forward attack the
Knight if the pawns get
traded I guess there's takes takes and
Knight H5 hitting
G7 but I don't think I would mind that
yeah there will be moves to deal with
that let's go for
F4 so now there's Pawn
between the F and E pawns so one of the
files is pretty likely to open we seen
that five which is a move I I was not
anticipating uh kind of a clever move
though cuz at first it looks like I can
win a pawn and F5 but if I take with the
bishop then uh my D Pawn can be taken
with
check
so have to be a little bit careful
here what I might do is leave the Knight
here for the time
being and take on
E3 yeah everything's defended in my
territory let's take on E3 so I like the
idea of provoking white to take back
with F Pawn and then eventually using
this
diagonal white could take with a
knight I think there's a lot of lines
where the Queen will come to H4 and
cause a lot of havoc in White's
position now of course Queen H4
immediately won't work Knight's
controlling
H4 but I can start looking
for more forcing
variations like even sacrificing The
Rook for the Knight like takes takes and
then Queen
H4 looks pretty
interesting and there's also G6
if I can simply chase the Knight
away like one thing I'm looking at is
G6 if Knight takes Bishop I don't need
to take back Queen H4 is actually forc
checkmates Queen H4 King E2 and then
Queen have2
checkmates Another consideration is
taking here but it does allow Bishop
takes D5 and then takes back
back I mean that's probably good for
black I think G6 is just simpler
though so I really don't
see how white is going to save the
Knight and deal with these ideas like
even if the Knight moves back to G3 I
can play Queen H4 pinning the
Knight and only move to defend the
Knight would be Knight F1 and then I can
play E4 unleashing the
bishop I should note here that Knight
H6 would be Checkmate if I didn't have a
Pawn on E5 this Pawn is actually very
clutch in blocking this diagonal uh
thankfully with Knight H6 I can play
King
G7 and then the Knight is basically
trapped on the side of the
board okay we do see Knight takes D6 so
yeah as I mentioned previously there's
no need to take back the knights uh this
is checkmates next
move white has
to play the delayed Bon
Cloud so I mean another opening that
started solidly
and ended pretty
roughly um I mean when when I first saw
the opening I thought this would be a
much longer battle I think we we see the
power of the early Pawn break and even
just a few lines opening up between the
file and these
diagonals uh just led to the destruction
of the white
king and white is realizing their
Doom casting King side is not legal for
a couple Reasons I'm checking the king
also controlling F1 so I guess now it's
a question how long will
white deliberate okay not too
long and uh another feel-good finish 14
move
win um yeah going back I mean hopefully
this is an instructive idea like with
this Pawn on G4 especially the power of
F5 can be very strong and I guess that's
why like usually when you play such a
setup for white you should probably keep
the pawn back on G3 and then it's it's
much harder for black to crack like if
we play through some simar moves maybe I
would still go for this F5 expansion and
then try and prepare F4 that probably be
the game
plan but uh yeah white is still pretty
solid here with the hippo
formation so uh that was the second game
of this episode hopefully some lessons
to take away let's keep moving on rated
1071 new 10
game playing toas
SG from Norway and we have a queen's
Pawn so actually getting a nice mix of
openings because there have been
previous episodes in the speedrun that
have been basically all King's Pawn
opening today we've seen a French a kind
of a hippo and now a Queen's
Gambit um I like to play the Queen's
Gambit declined I think it's the easiest
opening to play against the Queen's
Gambit very
solid and against Knight C3 there are a
lot of different moves black can play
here uh there's Bishop B4 the r goes in
is taking which is Vienna C5 is the
Tash the move I've been enjoying
recently and I think I'll go for in this
position is Knight
bd7 and this is called the barman
variation and it's not a move that black
needs to play right away but it can lead
to one of my favorite defenses
against the Queen's Gambit which is
called the Cambridge Springs and that
would happen after E3 and queen A5 so
okay we'll uh get that on the board this
is the very beginning position of the
Cambridge Springs and it's an opening
that I
learned maybe a little bit later in my
chess career maybe around like the 18 or
1900 level uh actually Grandmaster Yuri
Schulman was the first person to teach
me it cuz there was a time where I was
struggling against D4 and uh he showed
it to me and there's some cool traps
with this move that exploit the pin
against the Knight but also the bishop
on
G5 and queen B3 it does look solid
reinforcing C4 and
C3 but I'm pretty sure this move is a
small
mistake because of Knight
E4 and another purpose of Queen A5 was
to
unpin my kingside knight so so now I can
move it exerting pressure on the Knight
but also the bishop and there's a lot of
players here that will
blunder the fact that the Knight and
queen are both targeting the bishop and
this is a great example Bishop D3 looks
like a natural move but here it's back
to move and win a piece and I think
there's actually a few different ways I
can win a piece I can start by taking
which hits the queen and then take
take or I can take
first I really don't see a difference I
think I'll take first keep it
simple and once the Knight takes back I
take the pawn and it's a a feel-good
opening trap attacking the queen and the
bishop and the Knight no way for white
to save
everything so yeah I've I played the
Cambridge Springs a decent amount over
my chest career uh more recently in
online Blitz and rapid and every so
often players will uh lose a piece
pretty quickly in the opening as white
this opponent wanting to lose more
pieces uh sacking on E6 this does looks
scary at first as the queen will come in
uh but the problem for white
is I have so many things to defend I
have two extra minor pieces and the
queen can't really do much damage on its
[Music]
own ready to probably move the Knight
and hit the queen on E6 with the
bishop maybe white can try this move
Knight E4 threatening Knight D6 also
threatening the
queen I do have to be careful here
actually
because yeah Knight D6 it's kind of
unpleasant I think what I'd like to
do
is move my queen to check the the white
king just so my Queen's not hanging and
then I'll deal with this
threat but yeah even after like a really
nice opening I'm up two pieces for what
two Bishops for two pawns I still have
to be careful can't celebrate too
early white is likely going to move the
king
and now it's a question I mean I could
deliver another check like Queen
B5 there's defensive moves too there's
Queen C7 which stops Knight
D6 Queen B4 actually comes to
[Music]
mind and that helps cover D6 and attack
the
pawn as Queen
C7 Queen C7 probably is is the simplest
there is this move Knight
G5 but then I'm thinking I have to move
Knight E5 to hit the queen defend
F7 and then probably leading to a lot of
Trades going play Queen
[Music]
C7 and really I just need one more move
to move the Knight
and basically solve all my
[Music]
problems so Knight D6
um yeah this move it looks scary cuz my
Bishop's pinned but I can just take it
and once the queen takes Back The
Bishop's no longer pinned so still plays
a role in defending my
queen I don't know if people can hear
that there's there's ambulance sounds
outside uh okay someone calling
ambulance maybe for the white king let's
Castle yeah
now I mean I still want to develop I
want to get my knight and Bishops into
play
um no need to do anything too crazy just
Knight F6 Bishop G4 likely
coming and the goal here is to use all
my extra material to attack either to
try and win more material or just to
checkmates the white King Play Bishop G4
if King here or here I'll have a
fork yeah no
mercy King will be forced back I'll take
the
queen and then the plan will be to
somehow maneuver the queen into the the
white
territory but we don't need to go that
far okay so nice example of kind of the
Venom of the Cambridge Springs I mean
white played what is probably the most
common setup in the Queen's Gambit um at
least this is the most common
configuration of White's pieces uh but
against Queen A5 white does need to be
very careful white fell for one of the
the main tactical ideas that black has
in this opening um I should note that
Bishop D3 is another way for white to go
wrong even though it looks like a very
solid move there's takes takes and ight
E4 and it's another case where black is
winning material
so usually what white should do in this
opening uh there are a few different
moves uh the safest is Bishop takes F6
just remove the bishop ensuring it's not
a Target uh there's also Knight D2 to
obstruct the pin also control
E4 uh also C takes D5 is a popular move
among Grand
Masters so again hopefully some lessons
to take away rated
1079 and my voice is uh I think is
running out of steam so I don't know if
I'll break 1100 this episode but I'll do
at least one more try and stay
hydrated sticking with E4 and we have a
sicilian so no repeat openings uh this
episode and D6 is the most common
move and against this uh of course D4 is
open Sicilian most common move I'm going
to play uh Pawn C3 the so-called delayed
alipin and my opponent very quickly
playing Pawn D5 which I don't think I've
seen this specific move
before um I mean very often if flight
play C3 on move two then D5 is a move
but it's as if I got a free Tempo here
because the Knight is developed and
against this move I'll just
take and um yeah get ready to play D4
um I mean this is probably still
playable for black but it is nice having
an extra Tempo in the opening with the
white pieces can develop a little bit
more
rapidly and in this position there are a
few different ways to develop um I could
start with Bishop
E3 to maybe exert some pressure against
C5 and I actually like that move Bishop
E3 so I'm not sure if I want to put the
bishop on E2 or D3 or B5 just
yet okay we see Knight
C6 now there's a move that comes to mind
actually there's a few moves that come
to
mind one move is to take the pawn
because after let's say the queen trade
takes takes I would lose casting rights
but I'm up a pawn there before would be
coming the pawn supported by the bishop
so that would be one option I'm not sure
about it though cuz if takes takes takes
black could maybe play Knight G4 and
disturb my bishop and maybe I'd concede
the bishop hair
so uh yeah there's probably compensation
for lack in that
line another move that comes to mind I
think is a lot more aggressive this this
move Pawn
C4 which takes advantage of the fact the
Queen's attacked if doesn't have this
check on
e4 and yeah basically wherever the queen
moves I would have D5 next to attack the
Knight so I think I'll go for
this and this is a nice example of
basically seizing the
initiative initiative is a very common
very important Concept in chess usually
refers to situations where you're making
continual threats so C4 attacked the
queen D5 now attacks the knights
and with every move I'm gaining space
improving the position and pushing black
to lesser attractive
squares uh we see Knight B4 so I can
keep the initiative with
A3 I can also take the
pawn on C5 which is not
defended if I want to play this move I
guess I have to calculate Queen
A5 attack the bishop setting up some
discoveries I mean there's a line like
takes and then takes and then Queen
D2 so it's really a question do I want
to win a pawn and trade some pieces or
do I want to play play
A3 and try and keep the attack going and
after A3 Knight
A6 it looks good for white
but honestly I think I'd rather just win
the pawn
like win the pawn and trade keeping my
pawns intact I was going to say that
maybe black can consider this move to
get the bishop in but then I would have
Queen A4 check so Knight A6 so I'm
actually getting The Best of Both Worlds
Knight has retreated I won the pawn and
hopefully I can keep the
attack um I'll move back to
D4 centralizing the
bishop
now it's a very very pleasant
position Queen A4 check comes to mind
Queen A4 there's Bishop
D7 let's just develop no need to
overthink probably get ready for Bishop
E2 okay so with
B6 it looks like black is wanting to
prepare Knight C5 but the draw La of B6
leaves a knight undefended and this is a
very classic double attack so no mercy
in this
game winning the
Knight you see Knight to
D7 um I mean whenever you're about to
venture into your opponent's position
with the queen just want to make sure
that there's no way for the queen
to be exploited but yeah there's very
few moves to even attack the queen
like this or this don't really do
much my pawns do get
doubled but that's okay let's uh
trade and now I can win even more
material Queen
C6 forcing Queen D7 only legal move and
I'll pick up the Rook on
A8 so we might see resignation in this
position black uh black will be down lot
of material
yeah so another uh pretty
straightforward
game um I think this game black was
maybe a bit imprecise with the opening
playing
D5 after having played D6 on move two uh
the better move for black against this
opening would be Knight F6 to attack the
pawn which basically prevents Pawn
D4 and
um I don't want to analyze this opening
too much in depth but
against Knight F6 I would play Bishop E2
with the Trap that if Knight takes E4 I
have Queen A4 check and uh then White's
ready to Castle play Rook E1 and still
save D4 for
later so I mean in the game black went
for this D5
move and yeah maybe it was here that
instead of Knight C6 black should take
first I would take back and then maybe a
move like e six does look a little bit
passive but at least black would get
ready to develop in Castle and not have
to suffer the same things of me
expanding with my Pawns in the
center so yeah I think once I played C4
it was pretty smooth
sailing um I think black should have
played Queen
A5 but yeah after Knight
A6 um life was very good for white so I
think I'll end it there ending on a nice
note rated 1087
so hopefully in the next episode I will
break 1100 uh thanks everyone for
watching if you like the content like
And subscribe does help the channel if
you have questions leave them below look
forward to reading the comments and stay
tuned for the next video see you guys
soon